Cometemos tres errores:
Ee primero es infravalorar la cantidad
de información que producimos cada día;
el segundo es despreciar
el valor de esa información
y el tercero es pensar que
nuestro principal problema
es una agencia distante y
superpoderosa que se llama NSA.
Y es verdad que la NSA tiene
el mayor acceso, los mejores recursos,
las mejores herramientas,
pero no les hace falta nada de eso
para espiarnos a nosotros,
porque nosotros lo tenemos todo ahí.
Vivimos en casas de cristal.
Este es Malte Spitz, miembro
del Partido Verde alemán,
y en 2009, Malte le pidió
a su compañía telefónica
que le mandara todos
los datos que tenía sobre él.
Y la Deutsche Telekom, que era
su compañía, le dijo que no.
Dos demandas más tarde, le mandaron
un CD con un Excel de 30 832 líneas,
como La Guerra y la Paz pero tres veces.
Este documento interminable comprende
desde septiembre de 2009
hasta febrero de 2010;
tiene exactamente seis meses.
Y no es casual, tiene seis meses
porque en verano de 2008
la Unión Europea presentó
la directiva de retención de datos,
donde les exige que cada
compañía telefónica
con más de 10 000 clientes
guarde los datos de todos sus clientes
durante un mínimo de seis meses
y un máximo de dos años.
A Malte le dieron
seis meses como diciendo
"esto es todo lo que tenemos
porque nos obliga la ley".
Probablemente le deben un año y medio.
Entonces, Malte,
que no podía leer máquina,
se lo mandó a
un semanario que a su vez,
contactó con una agencia
devisualización de datos
para hacer algo con esto, ¿no?
Entonces ellos cogieron
estos datos de Deustche Telekom
y otros datos de Malte que eran públicos
como, por ejemplo, de su cuenta
de Twitter o de su blog.
Y con esto hicieron este mapa
que estáis viendo ahora,
que más que un mapa,
es como un diario automático
y terrorífico de la vida de Malte.
Podemos ver cuándo va en tren,
qué es lo que está haciendo ahora mismo,
cuándo se para, dónde se queda,
cuándo va, cómo va,
cuánto tiempo está,
cuándo está comiendo,
cuándo está durmiendo,
como ahora mismo...
Cuándo coge un avión, quién le llama,
cuánto tiempo le llama,
quién le manda mensajes, qué mensajes...
Lo vemos todo.
Esto está en la Web, eh. Lo podéis ver.
El motivo por el que pasa esto es
que Malte tiene un teléfono en el bolsillo
que cada cinco minutos hace un ping
a la antena que tenga más cerca y le dice:
"¿Tienes algo para mí?
¿Tengo algún correo?
¿Tengo algún mensaje de WhatsApp?
¿Ha pasado algo en el mundo?"
Levantad la mano los que tenéis un
teléfono en el bolsillo que hace lo mismo.
Entonces, nuestros teléfonos,
cada cinco minutos, están diciendo:
"estoy aquí, estoy aquí, ahora estoy aquí,
oye, que estoy aquí..."
Y esto es lo que pasa.
Y esto no tiene precedentes.
Esto no lo teníamos antes.
El equivalente directo es esto
que tenéis ahora en la pantalla.
Esto es el perfil de una persona
vigilada por la Stasi durante años.
Es como una servilleta, ¿no?
Con 46 post its ahí que incluyen
a su tía, el lechero,
el cura de su parroquia...
Esto son cinco minutos
en la vida de Malte Spitz,
y esta información es automática.
Y lo peor es que esto es solo
la información sobre Malte,
pero Malte está rodeado de gente
como nosotros con teléfonos como el suyo,
que están produciendo
la misma información;
y esa compañía los ve todos.
Esta es una foto de
mi compañero Juanlu Sánchez;
es una foto del 15-M.
Pero veámosla desde el punto
de vista de las telecomunicaciones.
Esta plaza está llena de móviles.
Con esos móviles podemos saber
exactamente quién está en la plaza,
casi como si pusiéramos
un cordón alrededor, ¿no?
Con nombres y apellidos.
Y no solo sabemos cuándo han venido,
de dónde han venido, con quién vienen,
con quién se van, a quién llaman...
Lo sabemos todo sobre ellos.
Sabemos incluso si están en
el 4° piso o están abajo en la plaza.
Esto es como ve esa foto
un algoritmo de análisis de tráfico.
Y aquí ya empezamos
a ver un poco cosas chulas, ¿no?
Vemos que no toda la gente
que está en la plaza es igual;
hay gente más importante que otra.
Entonces, si tenemos control sobre estas,
digamos, telecomunicaciones,
sobre esta red,
podemos hacer cosas como, por ejemplo,
apagar los nodos de esta plaza, es decir,
aislar a las personas que reúnen
a todos los demás, de todos los demás.
También podemos hacer lo que hizo
el gobierno de Ucrania hace año y medio
y mandarles un mensaje que ponga:
"Queridos usuarios, ha sido usted
registrado como partícipe
en una manifestación ilegal masiva".
No nos comportamos igual
cuando sabemos que nos vigilan.
Desde Jeremy Bentham sabemos
que la mejor manera
de vigilar a una población
es que no sepan cuándo
los están vigilando y cuándo no.
A Malte, en esos seis meses,
le estaban vigilando el 78% del tiempo.
Y estamos hablando solo
de nuestros móviles.
No estamos hablando ni
de nuestros ordenadores,
ni de las cámaras que hay en la calle,
y en las tiendas y en los escaparates
y en los aeropuertos y en los trenes
y en dondequiera que estemos
y que no vemos...
No estamos hablando de los radares
de las carreteras, que registran más,
que si nos pasamos de velocidad...
No estamos hablando de
lo que tenemos en la cartera.
¿Cuántos chips de identificación
personal tenemos en la cartera?
Tenemos muchos:
tenemos el DNI,
el carné de conducir
o el abono transporte;
tenemos la tarjeta de crédito,
de débito, de puntos...
La tarjeta de puntos del supermecado.
Hace 20 años, la base de datos
personal más grande del mundo
no la tenía la NSA,
y no la tenía la Stasi, pobrecita;
la tenía Walmart, la cadena
de supermercados estadounidense.
¿Por qué? Porque cuando
te dan una tarjeta de puntos,
lo que estás haciendo es decirle
a una empresa quién eres, dónde vives,
cuánto ganas, en qué te lo gastas,
qué comes, cuántos hijos tienes,
cuándo te vas de vacaciones,
cuándo te pones enfermo...
Y todo con la esperanza de que,
dentro de seis meses o de un año,
si te gastas mucho dinero,
te dan un tupper[ware].
(Risas)
Y no es distinto de
lo que hacemos en la red,
porque Deutsche Telekom es
una empresa legítima y europea,
que tiene que obedecer la Ley de
Protección de Datos, igual que Telefónica.
Telefónica, aquí, tiene que obedecer
leyes de protección de datos,
pero las empresas...
no es lo mismo con las empresas
que nos hacen los móviles,
que nos hacen los sistemas operativos,
que nos ofrecen correos "gratuitos",
que nos dan esas apps que nos bajamos
y que nos piden permiso
para un montón de cosas raras y decimos:
"Para algo lo querrán".
Lo quieren para venderlo.
¿Para qué quiere Angry Birds
tener acceso a tu GPS?
¡Para hacer dinero!
A nuestros vigilantes no les importa
que no seamos nadie,
que no seamos importantes,
porque son algoritmos, no son personas
y nuestro perfil es automático;
existe aunque nadie lo mire.
Y el dia que alguien lo mire
y te cambia la suerte,
tu perfil, tu historial, se convierte
en tus antecedentes.
Puedes acabar atascado
en el aeropuerto
de uno de los 75 países donde
ser homosexual es ilegal.
O puedes acabar en un país donde
echarle una foto a una farmacia
de producción masiva desde el otro lado
de la carretera es terrorismo;
esto pasa en Estados Unidos.
O puedes acabar en Siria, donde
le pegan tiros a la gente en la calle;
activistas, periodistas especialmente.
Puedes acabar en México, D.F.
donde Los Zetas tienen acceso
a la información de las telefónicas
para ver quién contacta con la policía
y cortarles la cabeza.
Hay mil maneras de estar en el sitio
equivocado en el momento equivocado
y a veces ni siquiera te tienes que mover.
En Holanda tenían un censo,
y era un censo que incluía religiones,
con la mejor intención del mundo.
Querían saber cuántos protestantes,
cuántos católicos y cuántos judíos tenían,
para saber cuánto dinero tenían
que poner en cada comunidad,
en cada iglesia o sinagoga.
¿Qué pasa? Que cuando llegaron los nazis,
ya tenían los deberes hechos.
Solo el 10% de los judíos holandeses
sobrevivieron a la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Si esa base de datos no existiera,
la cifra había sido muy distinta.
Lo que quiero decir es que
nuestro problema no es la NSA,
y no son los gobiernos corruptos,
y no son las compañías ambiciosas
que quieren vender nuestros datos,
y no son las personas malas,
y no tiene nada que ver
ni con sus intenciones
ni con sus malas intenciones.
El problema es que la existencia
misma de esa información
nos hace vulnerables de maneras que
no podemos ni anticipar ahora mismo.
Tenemos que poner cortinas
en nuestras casas;
no podemos esperar a
que nos las pongan por fuera.
Tenemos que ponerlas ya.
Tenemos que empezar a usar
criptografía en nuestros móviles,
en nuestras comunicaciones,
en nuestros ordenadores.
Empezar a pensarlo bien cada vez
que alguien nos ofrece
una tarjeta de puntos,
y decir: "Mmm..."
No solo por nosotros,
porque además,
este estado de vigilancia es
una de las peores enfermedades
que tiene una democracia.
Así que, os convido a llegar a casa,
empezar a usar Tor,
y si alguien quiere ver
lo que estáis haciendo,
que pida una orden de registro.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
[Nuevas charlas cada semana en www.TED.com]